Why is it so dark probably would have
been a good idea to have like one light on
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new shazam 2 teaser video the director david
sandberg released this first look at the movie
obviously to show off shazam's brand new upgraded
costume they'll all have costumes like this
so i'll explain what's going on with the movie
what's going on with the new villains that they've
announced they've already announced most of the
characters and they've already talked about how
they're going to be crossing him over with black
adam in future movies as well if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's actually a lot of big dc movie
stuff happening right now we actually just got
our first look at michael keaton's batman in the
flash movie don't worry i'll be talking about that
in a separate video just because there's so much
stuff going on with batman in the next couple of
years between all the different batman movies as
far as i know there is no batman anywhere inside
shazam 2 though one of the few places that does
not feature a batman movie even though there will
probably be batman references just like there
were batman references in the first film i'll
talk about the footage first then i'll talk about
what's going on with the actual movie but if you
couldn't tell the scene is an actual scene from
the movie that he basically just filmed because
they just started filming the movie and they just
posted it online even though he's joking about it
being too dark probably should have brought a
light a lot of you probably noticed that the
room that he's standing in is the same dining room
of the foster home where the shazamly lives it's
the same dining room where they all sat around the
table in the first film and held hands and chanted
their little mantra about being a family that
was meant to foreshadow the big twist where billy
eventually shares his powers of shazam with all
them but as you can tell the way they pan around
the costume they added way more ornate designs and
etchings to all the metal pieces they actually do
look like real metal now the director talked about
when they were creating the first version of the
costume for the original shazam movie they went
through all kinds of different designs and just
practically had a bunch of issues with trying to
film in it all kinds of weird problems so it took
them a while to find a costume that was easy to
film and that wouldn't fall apart it just sounds
like they've used the time since making that first
film to make a costume that's easier for them to
film in practically but also that incorporates
much more ornate designs like it looks way more
hardcore you can see way more definition in the
musculature it doesn't look quite as cartoonish as
the last suit and even though it doesn't look like
it in some of these behind the scenes picks he is
wearing the cape here they're just using visual
effects to do the cape and some of these action
scenes just in general the suit itself looks
like it's much more ancient like the original
suit from the first film looked more modernized
and simplistic in its design like i said kind
of cartoonish but i think that's because they
were playing it pretty safe with the way they
made the suit they wanted it to look closer to
the new 52 designs and this time around in the
sequel they're going with more of a classic look
but here's the thing you may have also recently
seen the rock teasing his black adam suit because
he's been posting behind the scenes pictures from
the black adam movie they have been filming it we
haven't got a full costume reveal from him yet but
i wouldn't be surprised if some of these changes
in the new shazam suits for shazam 2 were meant
to make them look a little more similar to the
black adams suit in the comics for the most part
all their suits are the same black adam and the
shazam family members really when you see the
suits change design it's just because a new artist
comes onto the comic book and they want to make
the characters look just a little bit different
the only real big differences in some of the
versions of the suits are the female suits because
they have skirts but otherwise black adam's suit
is meant to look very similar if not the exact
same as shazam suit but through their powers they
are able to give themselves different variations
of suits like he could change the suit if he
wanted to if he learned more about his magical
powers the other thing you probably detected in
that was the veiled justice league joke justice
league snyder cut so he's joking about it being
too dark in the house there in the shazam lee's
house because of the comedic tone of the shazam
character just in general and in the scene that
they're filming here the family has the lights in
the house turned down for some reason like maybe
they're trying to surprise him or something or
they're getting ready for a big action scene
or something funny is about to happen but the
comment about the darkness is also meant to be
a reference to the ending of the justice league
snyder cup like the joke that ryan reynolds made
in deadpool 2 about the dc universe being so dark
we all just got done watching the justice league
snyder cut just a little while ago and it was by
far the most hardcore dc movie next to watchmen
coincidentally also a zack snyder movie i did a
ton of justice league snyder cut videos all
about the easter eggs in the ending scenes and a
full breakdown of what was going to happen in the
sequels justice league 2 and justice league 3 had
zack snyder been allowed to make those he posted
all the storyboards which were hand drawn on these
giant wall sides boards by jim lee himself they
look badass i'll add a link for that video for the
justice league sequels in the description below
because the plot of the sequels was mind-blowing
it was crazy how big it was going to get but in
terms of the way that movie ends with a nightmare
scene and how it affects the timeline of other
dc movies like shazam 2 the flash movie because
you very literally have ezra miller coming off of
the justice league snyder cut into the flash movie
in all the other upcoming dc movies for the most
part the way zack snyder talks about it explains
it he says that both he in the studio consider the
justice league snyder cut to be part of a separate
continuity like separate timeline that they're
just referring to as the snyder verse of movies
all the movies that zack snyder made like man of
steel batman v superman and the justice league
movie or the justice league snyder cut so the
ending of the snyder cut isn't supposed to have
any real bearing on the plot of these upcoming
movies like the nightmare scene all the implied
time travel so even though ben affleck's batman
and ezra miller's flash are coming back for the
flash movie don't expect them to be talking like
they just came out of this huge time travel plot
with him just having spoken to martian manhunter
in the post-credits scene all that stuff was brand
new stuff that zack snyder added to the justice
league snyder gun like originally that was meant
to be a green lantern scene i've already done
separate videos about that too like he was going
to have a version of jon stewart green lantern
show up with killwag to talk to batman he posted
all this footage of it this is him talking about
his green lantern scene here but even though they
won't be talking a lot about the ending of the
snyder cut during the flash movie for instance
or even during shazam 2 there will still be a lot
of justice league references during the upcoming
dc movies like billy making meta jokes about
the snyder cut i'm sure other upcoming movies
featuring the same actors from the justice
league will at least have casual references
to the previous version of the team and also when
they do eventually do another justice league film
for whichever actors are still around for that
the way that zachary levi talks about it the
idea is is that shazam or at least billy will
join a future version of the justice league once
they are ready to make another film but no idea
when that would happen probably not at least for
three or four years bare minimum maybe even more
than that but you also have the idea that in the
black atom teaser trailer they released the dc
fandom i did a whole big video about that so i'll
put a link in the description but during that
the rock was actually teasing black adam versus
the justice league like he basically called them
all out put them on notice and was talking a lot
about crossing over with henry cavill superman
so in terms of other justice league characters
showing up in shazam 2 earlier last year there
was talk of a henry cavill superman cameo scene
because they had tried to do it for the first
film like we all saw that was his suit it was
meant to be him at the end of the movie but even
though warner brothers is now basically doing that
multiverse elseworlds version of the superman
movie with a different version of the character
that doesn't completely mean that henry cavill is
out as superman i think he would always come back
but a lot of it i think just depends on directors
coming along that want to use his version of
superman for the most part the way warner brothers
has talked about it they give the directors
free reign to do whatever they want to with the
characters now so if a director comes along and
wants his version of the character like if the
rock wants to do a superman crossover movie with
henry cavill superman then they can make that
happen if the schedule works out and if henry
cavill says yes to it but in terms of black adam
crossover the way zachary levi talked about it
their loose plan right now is to do the black adam
origin movie we'll see that that's coming out next
summer then separately they're doing shazam 2 fury
the gods and that will not feature a lot of black
adam they won't cross them over until whatever the
next movie winds up being like shazam 3 or shazam
versus black adam whatever they decide to call
that film but maybe some kind of post credit scene
and also just in terms of stuff that carries over
from earlier post credit scenes and crossovers
mark strong said that dr savannah and mr mind
aren't really big characters during shazam 2.
now they will probably be referenced at some point
during the film maybe like a post-credits scene
but he said for the most part he is not going
to be a big character during this sequel
i think because they're leaving him for the big
black atom crossover movie to be one of the larger
villains with mr mine like mr mind will wind
up being a bigger villain than black adam does
because the way they're pitching the black
adam character in the dc universe he's more
of an anti-hero so in order to make him feel like
an anti-hero you need somebody who's even worse
and in the comics that does wind up being mr
mind the actual villains of shazam 2 are going
to be the daughters of the greek titan atlas so
it's all based on the powers of the shazamly so
the shazam name is actually an acronym it's the
wisdom of solomon the strength of hercules the
stamina of atlas the power of zeus the courage
of achilles and the speed of mercury so the three
new characters that they've announced are helen
mirren as hespera one of the daughters of atlas
kalypso played by lucy liu who's one of the other
daughters of atlas this titan and then there's a
third character being played by rachel ziegler who
people think might wind up being one of the other
daughters there was an earlier rumor that they'd
be playing the three greek fates mythologically
but if you're not big on greek mythology the
characters that they're based on have slightly
different backstories like the three fates are a
different group of characters than the daughters
of the titan atlas but the whole idea is the titan
atlas is the titan that gives them their stamina
like stamina of atlas so the title shazam fury of
the gods is a reference to them facing the fury of
the gods that give them their power i don't want
to get too deep into the weeds on greek mythology
here because they're obviously going to simplify
a lot of this they won't be doing everything from
these characters mythologies and histories but the
whole idea is that these daughters are basically
nymphs from greek mythology helen mirren's name
hespera is based on the hesperides which is a
mythological group of nymphs that basically tend
to hera's orchard in the west where these really
special golden apples grow they contain a lot
of power and they figure into this much bigger
story of the 12 labors of hercules they adapted
some of this for the video game series god of war
hera being very jealous of hercules drives him
mad and in his madness he winds up killing his
human sons and in order to atone for his actions
the oracle of delphi tells him to go serve his
cousin who's a king in a neighboring country and
just perform whatever tasks that he gives him
and his cousin the king gives him these 10 labors
to perform the reason why the tail is called the
12 labors of hercules is because twice he actually
gets help or it doesn't quite work the way the
king wants it to work so he makes him do two extra
labors so it becomes the 12 labors of hercules
the 11th labor is the one where he has to go
steal the golden apples from the hesperides
in order to do that he winds up tricking
the titan atlas to steal the golden apples
from his daughters for him so i wouldn't be
surprised if during shazam 2 part of the movie is
inspired by the 12 labors of hercules like shazam
billy in the shazamly have to perform some of the
labors of hercules what'll probably happen though
is because they're a little further along in the
filming of the black adam movie is that we'll get
the first big trailer for black adam later this
year of course i'll be doing videos for that
movie as well they're introducing a version of
the justice society like i said i've already
done a couple videos for the teaser trailers
they've released so i'll post links for those
down in the description but if you have any big
questions about what's going on with the shazam
movie shazam 2 the black adam movie the sequels
let me know in the comments below i will do a
separate video about that michael keaton batman
teaser that they released for the flash movie
that should post sometime tomorrow but next week
the loki series is starting i'll be doing videos
for all the episodes so make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss any of that but while
you wait for everything everyone click here for
that brand new thor 4 love and thunder first look
teaser and click here for my brand new eternals
trailer video about kit harington's black knight
character and his future in the avengers movies
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!